Hello, everyone and
welcome to today's session
of the BD2K Fundamentals of
Data Science webinar series,
where each week we present
a new lecture giving us
a background in the
foundations of data science.
And it's a real pleasure to
introduce today's speaker.
Her name is Lucila Ohno-Machado.
Lucila is Professor of Medicine
at the University of California
San Diego and Chair of the
Department of Biomedical
Informatics.
Lucila has had a
distinguished career.
She received her MD from
the University of San Paulo,
received her MBA, went
to Stanford in the 1990s,
received her PhD.
Musen, and I can
say that I'm pleased that she
got her PhD with me, which
makes me very, very proud.
Lucila has lots of honors.
She's an elected member of the
American Society for Clinical
Investigation and a fellow
of the American College
of Medical Informatics.
She edits the Journal of the
American Medical Informatics
Association.
But most important,
she directs a project
through the BD2K program
related to finding, accessing,
interoperating with
and using data.
And that's going to be the topic
of Lucila's talk this morning.
Before Lucila speaks,
let me remind everyone
that you're all on mute
because there's so many people
listening into this call.
As you have questions
during the talks today,
please put your questions
into the chat box and we'll
be sure that we can
send those questions
to Lucila for her comment
at the end of the hour.
And we're looking forward to
hearing what Lucila has to say.
Go ahead.
Thank you, Mark, and
thanks to the organizers
for the opportunity to
present this project, which
is the Data Discovery Index
Consortium that we are leading
together with collaborators
from the University of Michigan,
University of Oxford, and also
University of Texas Houston.
So I'm presenting on
behalf of all of them.
And I'll try to monitor the
question box as I speak.
So I would like to start
with the motivation for this.
And this is one that I'm
personally interested in.
For example, a question about
could I get all data about
astrocytomas with
TP53 mutations.
And, in particular, I'm
interested in the stage two
type of tumors.
Can I get images?
Can I get medical records?
Can I get other type of data
so I could assess survival
or I could assess recurrence
in other items of interest?
And, believe it or not, if
you're trying to do that today,
it is very cumbersome and
you don't find everything
that you should.
So we started with the Data
Discovery Index Consortium
with the goal of helping
users find shared data,
build a prototype for data
discovery index, a search
engine, and interoperate
in the Commons.
So in accordance to
the FAIR principles,
our primary goals are
to find and access data.
And the other I and
R are also desirable,
but are not the total focus
of our projects as of now.
Our goal is to do
for data what PubMed
did for papers, that is
make them discoverable
and make them accessible.
BioCADDIE started effectively
about 1 and 1/2 years
ago with our set of priorities.
And I'm pleased to say
that after 1 year and 1/2
we have a lot to show.
This is a slide
from Ron Margolis
that he presented at our
all hands meeting that
happened just a few weeks ago.
And he had the task
to show others,
or to show the
bioCADDIE team, where
we fit into the digital
data Commons for NIH.
And in his slide here,
he shows this stack
of items that are
anticipated for the Commons
and how data and
reference data sets are
such an important foundation
for that, and with that,
all digital objects as well
with software, with systems
workflows, and so on.
And this is all on top of
Compute Platform, which
can be cloud.
It can be high performance
computing clusters.
So in this slide I
just show my view
that pre-curated data
turns into curated data.
And it's annotated as
metadata are included.
And then analytics happen.
In analytics, it is the
priority of many of the BD2K
centers of excellence.
And this is how it
all ties together.
They are hosted in a
cloud, a cluster server.
In our case, we do a
lot with HIPAA data,
not necessarily in bioCADDIE,
but in many other projects,
that is human
subjects that needs
to be protected with a
certain type of regulations.
And it's often the case
that you combine this data.
So in my example, you are
looking for medical records
determining the
rate of recurrence,
the survival of a
particular type of tumor,
so you want to combine
publicly available data
with HIPAA compliant data.
And then when you join items,
you create another dataset.
And that other dataset
can also be annotated
and be pre-processed and entered
into an analytical process.
So that's why I believe
it all comes together
and we should join
forces in terms
of indexing all these
objects so we can reuse them
and can make the analysis
reproducible later.
And journals and publications
are not out of the loop
because they are the end
product of all of this.
And they're a little
bit of a circle,
in a loop in themselves.
So the bioCADDIE project,
the main components
are working groups,
metadata specifications,
software development,
collaborations,
and administration.
I actually proposed this
project initially thinking
it would be a research project.
But clearly it was also an
engineering and technical
project.
But most of all, it
is a social project
in which collaborations
are critical
and engagement of
a large community
makes the project
much more impactful.
So the way we view bioCADDIE
and its Data Discovery Index
prototype is that we will
develop a search engine
that people can access to show
what is involved in getting
digital objects indexed.
This search engine,
as with anything
else, can be replaced by
another search engine,
another front end, and so on.
But what's important is that
the data and the objects
get indexed in such a
way that this search
engine can find them.
Additionally, we
want pilot projects
from other institutions to
be integrated into the Data
Discovery Index so
people can develop
different portions of this DDI.
And together we get much
further than we would otherwise.
An important aspect,
also, is that we
want to index data aggregators.
That means we want to
index other indices.
We don't want to
reproduce that work.
And, in fact, we want to make
sure users can get to them
when they are searching
for particular objects.
Like I said, in our case, we're
searching across a wide variety
of data types.
And those aggregators tend to
focus on a particular data type
and are much more detailed
than we would ever
be able to be if we set out
to index absolutely everything
ourselves.
So one example that
will be given here
is the Omics Data Discovery,
the Data Index project,
that I'll show.
And it's in collaboration
with the Heart BD2K center
and with the ELIXIR colleagues.
So what we have here is just
another illustration of-- we
have big data sets, for example,
from the NIH conference that we
will index, we are
indexing at this moment.
We are also providing
links that are
indexed to aggregator services.
So this was a pilot project
that Henning Hermjakob
leads in collaboration with
bioCADDIE and the Heart BD2K
center.
And it's the Omics
Discovery Index.
So, again, it has
its own search engine
and it has indexed Omics
objects to a very high extent.
So what we do is integrate
with this aggregator,
and, therefore, not
replicate the work.
But let's say we were
trying my search.
We would find the Omics
datasets on astrocytomas,
but we would also find
images, hopefully,
and find clinical data.
So that's the goal
of being an umbrella
index for all those other
ones that we help integrate.
So the OmicsDI is one
of several examples.
But it's the one that
was a supplement funded
to the project and I'm
happy to display here.
There are others as well.
So the goal is to get these
repositories, the datasets,
and the date aggregators,
and adjust that metadata
so we can do this uber
index into a search engine,
provide users with pointers,
with results that are ranked
in order of relevance to them.
In order to do that, we
have a terminology server
that attempts queries and
also a ranking engine.
So some of you have
seen our presentation
at the last BD2K meeting.
We were in the beginning of
the road or in the middle here.
And we were designing
the prototype
so we can showcase what
the indexing is all about.
Where we are now, this
data engine, DataMed,
is already deployed.
And it's in version 1.0.
That you can see.
And together with it, it's
the metadata, which is also
finalized at this point.
So the front end of data
metalogs like this-- there
are 23 repositories now, many
more being indexed as we speak,
10 data types, 4 pilot
projects integrated,
and about 649,000
datasets at the moment.
Also, at the bottom
here you will
see the pilot projects that
have already been integrated
with three more to come.
And the way the
pilot projects work
is we issue a request
for applications.
And we have a peer
review process and then
issue subcontracts
to the projects
that were deemed most
relevant and most integrable
with bioCADDIE.
And here we have a
DataMed search engine,
how it looks like.
I encourage you all
to go to DataMed.org
and try it out for yourselves.
There are filtering by
facets, by data type,
by repository, by accessibility,
and authorization.
And so keep in
mind that in order
to filter by
accessibility, we do
need to have the
metadata about that.
And that's why one
of our working groups
has focused on it.
We can, again, filter by
repositories, specific facets,
and so on.
So upcoming, our path
ahead is depending
on a variety of factors.
But the goal was to
make a difference
in the way the data are shared.
So we have a dataset
retrieval challenge.
We are still having working
groups for certain items
that we are fine tuning and
integrating into the projects.
So in terms of the working
groups that I talked about,
they are a fundamental
piece of bioCADDIE.
They relate to use cases.
That's how we elicit
it-- use cases
through working groups define
criteria for inclusion,
define how we would
deal with identifiers,
define the metadata
specifications,
and what the graphical interface
would look like, usability
testing, and so on,
and, importantly, also
data citations and links to
publications, and then finally,
the evaluation.
So these were all
working groups that we
created surrounding the Data
Discovery Index Consortium so
that we could get members from
the community to participate
in the creation of it.
So one of the initial
working groups
is how we interacted with
the other BD2K centers
and other programs at NIH.
So we had developed some
supplemental projects--
I will present one
of them quickly--
with other centers shown here.
And there is one upcoming
with links as well,
and visualization, and ranking.
As I said, there's
often different modules
that can be either incorporated
to DataMed as a search engine
or be a search
engine in themselves.
We also have been in
contact with Common Fund
program about datasets that
they would like to be indexed.
And we had joint meetings all
through the streaming webinar.
We also plan to participate
in the called pilots.
With the identifiers, we decided
we will not mint identifiers
through bioCADDIE, but
we will use identifiers
that fully resolve to an URI.
And we should also maintain
a set of landing pages
for each of the datasets
indexed, including
forward ones that
may no longer exist,
so we needed to document the
persistence of this dataset.
The Identifier Working Group
was led by Jeff Grethe.
And there was a minimal
identifier pilot
in collaboration with
other BD2K centers
that is also ongoing, as well
as Data Citation Implementation
Pilot with the FORCE11
organization led by Tim Clark.
This Data Citation
Implementation Project
was a supplement to
bioCADDIE and allowed
even more members
of the community
to contribute to our efforts.
Another working group was
led by Susanna Sansone-- very
important, related to the
metadata specifications
and has gone through
several versions.
Now it's on 2.1.
And the important
thing to emphasize,
it was derived both from
a use case approach, which
we call a top-down approach
shown on the left-hand side,
as well as a bottom-up
approach, that
is looking into what
we had as metadata
already and trying to
reconcile several metadata
strategies in order to come up
with the minimal specifications
for DATS, which is the Data
Tag Suite, which is based
on the same principle as JATS,
which is the Journal Article
Tag Suite.
Meaning, at one point, once
that specification is very well
understood, data producers can
submit data or submit metadata
to bioCADDIE in the same way
that journal publishers submit
data to PubMed.
So that's our goal.
The working group representation
was from several institutions.
And some of them
are listed here.
And this is to say that
it wasn't us deciding
on the metadata specification,
but consultation
with many, many initiatives.
We also did use cases
and testing benchmarks.
And there is a report you can
find at how user analysis was
done and usability tests.
We also, as part of this,
created testing benchmarks.
So that's another
contribution that we perceive
as being long-lasting
because it's
a very laborious work in terms
of annotating and confirming
and validating
rankings of retrievals.
So this is now available.
And it will be used
for our challenge.
And after that, it will be
available to the community.
So the use cases
were essentially
creating these
benchmark data sets,
instantiating the queries,
running search engines,
and manually annotating
the quality of results.
We also had a working group
on Data Citation Metrics
because they are
important in order
to reward those
who share the data.
And the goals were to have
qualitative and quantitative
metrics that would talk
about issues such as when
the date were produced,
provenance, downloads, and then
rank results, and criteria
to restrict search that
could depend on search
metrics, for example,
the most popular datasets, that
is the most downloaded and so
on.
So this group dealt
specifically with this issue.
And the report is
also available online.
Another working group
that is very important
was to decide which
data repositories
we would index to get started
with our search engine.
And that is an
important distinction
between a search engine that
simply finds everything.
We wanted to convert at least
some degree of filtering
of quality control to
which datasets appear,
or at least in the
order in which they
appear in our search engine.
So we have come up with
some criteria here related
to prominence, sustainability,
scope, quality, and access,
and also with a
repository submission
workflow so that repositories
can approach us or we approach
them.
And then we work out on how we
should automate this metadata
mapping into our
specifications and how
to exert quality control
into the mapping and so on.
So, again, anyone who has
a repository out there who
wants it to appear right away
in bioCADDIE and DataMed, please
do let us know because
we are into a very
active process of doing this.
Many repositories are
being indexed as we speak.
And accessibility metadata
was also very important.
So lead by George Alter from
the University of Michigan,
a working group
decided what would
be the initial set of metadata
related to authorization,
authentication, and access.
And this has also been
incorporated into DATS 2.1.
And why is
accessibility important?
Because we do not want to limit
ourselves to public data only.
We know that there are several
very valuable datasets that
are under access control.
And users should
know that they exist
and then know also the
conditions by which they
could be accessible.
So privacy is very
important to us.
And one important project,
a supplemental project
that relates to it, is
named Count Everything.
And that is for secure
aggregating counts
of relevant patients across
different data types.
So we partnered with
the MD2K center,
with the PIC-SURE
center, and also
the Global Alliance for
Genomics and Health,
which is the translational
genomic center out of UC Santa
Cruz in order to come up with
a secure aggregated account.
Why is it important
for bioCADDIE?
The situation is as
follows-- remember,
I was looking for astrocytomas.
And suppose I was
looking for ones
that had mutations in TP 53
and I wanted the whole sequence
of that particular gene.
If I go by metadata only,
I would know that, yes,
I have whole genome sequence
data for those patients
that I identify.
However, I would
not know how many
have a particular mutation.
So if it's a dataset that has
no patients with mutations,
maybe it's not as
important to me
as having another dataset
in which 20% of the patients
have mutations in that
particular gene of interest.
So in order to organize the
way I would be requesting
those datasets, because they
are under access control,
it would be important
to know which
one has more of the
characteristics of the patients
I'm looking for.
So that's why counting
everything would be important.
But as you know, counting
can compromise privacy.
So that's where we
designed this in such a way
that it's done
through encryption.
And all those communications
and the aggregation
is done in a secure environment.
So this is a
supplemental project
that involves those three
other centers of excellence,
those other BD2K centers.
Continuing on the list
of working groups--
also a working group to
rank search results led
from the University of Texas
in Houston was conducted.
The report is online.
And their recommendations
are to empirically determine
which ranking algorithm from
the Elasticsearch family
would be best for us based on
evaluations against reference
sets and logs of user behavior--
since we now have a user basis
and they are continuously
accessing DataMed--
and provide alternative ranking
based on user preferences.
So this also is evolving as we
have more users to our search
engine.
End User Evaluation Criteria--
also very important.
And we are still
conducting this in terms
of saying, how do we
know we got there,
that we have a good
product for users?
Usage itself might
not be a good metric.
There can be other
measures of impact.
So this particular working
group was working on that.
Repository Contact Workflow--
this was led by George Alter.
How do we develop this
workflow in terms of having
a repository to index?
Who starts the process?
How is it tracked?
And so on.
How we prioritize
those that come to us.
There is now a committee
that has developed processes
and is following up with
this particular aspect.
Natural Language Processing
is also an important aspect
of our index
because, as you know,
it is very important to extract
structured data from narrative
text.
And, actually, we
have just issued
an extension on our dataset
retrieval challenge sign up.
So that we came up as--
there's a challenge that
has a very high
monetary award which
will be in the form of a
subcontract to the winners.
And there can be more than one.
Around $50,000 for this
particular challenge.
So if you're interested, please
do log in to Biocaddie.org
and look into this challenge.
The way it works
is that the winners
will have their
algorithms incorporated
into our data match prototype.
And we will make full
use of their work.
And we will compensate
for that as well.
And an independent
panel of judges
will be making
that determination.
So, also, for
ingestion and indexing,
I won't go through
many, many details.
I would ask you to
primarily follow
the boxes that are shown
here in this L-shaped format.
Because that's the process
by which the core development
team, led by Jeff
Grethe and by Hua Xu,
are developing this
ingestion of data sources
in order to get the metadata.
And there are important
interactions here,
and I would say that with
schema.org and with CEDAR.
So with schema.org we want
to be perfectly aligned
so that the metadata can
conform to schema.org
so it can be found by other
search engines and not
only DataMed.
Also, the collaboration
with CEDAR
is such that-- remember, there
were datasets that were not
already aggregated and that
the data contributors would
be annotating those data sets
or creating those metadata,
populating the metadata for us.
And we rely on CEDAR, that is
a center led by Mark Musen that
is developing these
forms in smart forms
so that data producers can
annotate their datasets.
Also, the DATS
metadata model was
developed by a working group
led by Susanna from Oxford.
And we are creating this
metadata transformation
so that it becomes
easier to reconcile
all of those strategies.
The requirements
for the metadata,
as I mentioned
before, were driven
by multiple stakeholders.
So as I said, it's
a social process
of reconciling all of this and
making it so that we're all
swimming in the same direction.
There was collaboration across
these multiple working groups
that I mentioned before in
order to get this ingestion
and indexing going through a
process that initially-- like
in number one, there
is a submission format,
we need to develop
adapters, and so on.
Evolving to number three,
in which we hope, and we
are structuring ourselves to
scale so that, similar to how
journalists currently
provide data to PubMed,
data providers will
provide data to DATS
without this more
manual process that
is currently involved in
populating the initial DataMed.
So as we evolve,
we become happier,
and we also scale the index,
how encompassing it is.
We also want to
enhance metadata,
that this will be a
continuous process.
And it will continue to
involve the community in that
as well as incorporate elements
of natural language processing
as we progress.
The final document preparation--
again, that is a pipeline here.
And in order to be scalable--
that pipeline process is
scalable horizontally--
large datasets
were full and has
been pipelined.
And DATS 2.1 models are
in the works right now.
And there is a high volume
of operations dedicated
to this at the moment.
We want to populate the
index as much as possible.
Scalable index
services as well--
we rely heavily
on Elasticsearch.
And we are also creating
APIs for developers
so they can build
their own modules
and utilize the indexed
data in their own ways.
This is another pilot project
that I wanted to highlight.
Pilot projects are,
like I said, those
that are competed through
a peer review process
and are awarded to
the ones that are
deemed more relevant to
bioCADDIE at this moment.
So one of them is led by Chris
Mungall from Lawrence Berkeley
National Laboratory
in collaboration
with other programs
displayed here.
And Chris' goal is to use
GitHub, YAML, and Markdown
in order to make, as he puts it,
making metadata annotation fun.
So it's a project
that, again, he
uses the capabilities
of GitHib in order
to have authors put
their metadata in there.
And this is ongoing.
But we've seen some
demonstrations of it already.
And it is, again,
showing alternatives
to what we had originally
thought the annotation
process could be.
And this is the value of
engaging the community.
We always have some
good ideas coming up.
And we can incorporate them
or put different modules
into our own development.
Another bioCADDIE
pilot project was
issued to the University of
Utah and to metadata data
discovery and
integration to support
repurposing of
heterogeneous data
using the OpenFurther Platform.
And this is, again,
another way of indexing
that this particular group
in Utah has proposed.
And we said, yeah,
let's try that, too.
Because the more
minds that think
about this process, the better.
Another one to complete-- there
were three this past year--
was the feasibility study of
indexing clinical research data
using HL7 FHIR, which is a
standard for clinical data
exchange that is very
popular these days.
And it's a pilot project
on a harvesting strategy
for the data discovery index led
by Harold Solbrig from the Mayo
Clinic.
So they had three deliverables.
One was metadata harmonization.
The other one was indexing
the dbGap phenotype variables.
And the third one
was exposing metadata
through schema.org,
which as I have mentioned
before is also our goal
with that, with our metadata
specification.
So we're very happy to
have those three pilot
projects this year.
And we'll have the natural
language processing next year.
And these are all,
again, available
for the community to come
up with the best ideas.
So we, essentially, see
bioCADDIE as having the Data
Shop component.
This is very technical--
indexing link,
linking to articles,
ontology-based tools.
We see the Data Showcase,
which is the front end that
uses Elasticsearch,
but essentially it's
about the graphical
interface, how we visualize,
how the usability of the
tool is meeting expectations.
And then there is the
whole Data Market,
which, again, it's a
social aspect of it
that is very important.
Because there need to
be incentives for data
sharing and for people to
annotate data very well.
And those incentives currently
are somewhat obscure.
And then, citation
networks need to develop,
because the same way as
publication citations
became the currency
of academic metrics,
the data citations might
become in the future at least
an important part of
the large ecosystem.
So in our bioCADDIE
Data Shop and Showcase,
we see as the repositories
contributing as something
happens inside this shop.
And then the products
are displayed
in an easy-to-see fashion
so that the researchers,
our clients or
customers, can decide
what they want to take
out of the store or not.
As I said, the Data Market
needs to be developed.
It is not fully developed.
BioCADDIE is one
front end of it--
or DataMed is one
front end of it.
There can be others.
And, again, the currency for
data has not been well-defined.
So it's very exciting to
be at this point in time
where we are helping define all
these elements for the NIH data
Commons.
And more than data we also see
these other digital objects
to have in this value.
And it will be software.
It will be software systems,
packaged as dockers,
packaged as VMs, or other sorts
of value that will be provided.
So we are, with the help
of a large community,
trying to create the
market, define the market,
and create the first tools,
so that after it exists,
others can come up with
even better tools, and even
better ways of indexing,
of accessing, and so on.
So we are at the beginning
of a long journey.
So here is the roadmap
created by the University
of Texas colleagues.
And as you see, we have met
the milestones from before.
We are still running there.
And there are public releases
of the new versions scheduled.
And they have improvements
on a variety of features
as determined by the community.
So please do experiment
with DataMed.
Don't expect to see
everything in there.
But it's there so
you get the idea
and you demand other datasets
and you demand improvements
in the user interface and
coverage of the datasets
that we have right now.
So our journey-- this
is a poor picture
that I took in the
Johannesburg airport.
If you have an opportunity,
please do take a better one.
But it says something
very important.
It says-- if you want to
go fast, you go alone.
If you want to go far,
then you go together.
It is an African proverb.
And we see bioCADDIE
as in that stage
that we were asked to go
fast, but we were also
asked to go far.
So we have engaged a large
community to go far with us,
to have an initial prototype
and then engaged the community
to challenge the community
to have better prototypes,
and to help us index
this huge volume
of data that are
out there, unused,
in a way that makes more
value for our dollars.
So with that, I
was also instructed
to leave plenty of
time for discussion.
So I have here the
two things that I
want you to remember from
this talk-- Biocaddie.org
and DataMed.org-- so that you
can fully understand what we're
doing through our
consultation with the website
and experimentation
with the search engine.
So, again, I would like to thank
the organizers for having given
me the opportunity to do this.
I did not list here all
collaborators for this project
in fear that I
would miss somebody.
And with so many collaborating--
more than 100 at this point--
that would certainly happen.
So I would like to thank
all collaborators, all
our members of the executive
committee of bioCADDIE
who have teamed up to come up
with the best of both worlds.
You know it's a consortium
that we put the best minds
to work into this very,
very challenging problem.
So, Mark, thank you,
again, for the opportunity.
Thanks, Lucila.
That was great.
I'm encouraging all
of the people who
are dialed into this
webinar to post questions.
Since everyone is muted,
please put your questions
into the chat box and we'll
try to get to them as we can.
So please put your questions
in the chat box now.
And we'll feed them to Lucila.
Before we do that,
Lucila, let me ask you,
you ended your talk
showing a roadmap.
And bioCADDIE has a
very ambitious goal.
How do you know
when you're done?
Do you have any sense for what
is the number of repositories,
what is the number of
datasets out there,
and how can you ever know
when to stop working?
Yeah, well, again, that's
why we had a full working
group on that, right?
But, also, yeah, I see we
have a lot to do still.
And I can say it has been
such a fast-paced project
that sometimes we don't
even have time to stop
and think of what's next, how
do we know when we're done.
And we think at
this phase there is
so much to be done that I
can't see the end very soon.
So in contrast with
the publication
world in which there
was a market already--
journals existed,
they were publishing,
they were having
their own websites,
and so on-- so in
contrast to publications,
data are more complicated
because it's not as organized
as that market was.
So at this point
we're just seeing
the tip of the iceberg, the
datasets that most people know
and have used, except that
they're scattered all around,
and except that as a user of
a particular type of data,
let's say for me
clinical data, I
know where to tap
into the sources.
But when I jump
into Image Data, I
don't know, or Omics, or others.
So there is so much out
there that we don't even
know-- that that's important
that those communities
specialized on these data
types be in this journey
together with us so we
don't miss anything.
But it is a very
important question,
but one that, unfortunately,
I don't have a good answer
for you right now.
I just see so much
ahead of us that I can't
see the end at this point.
Do you have any estimates
for what the denominator is?
How much biomedical
data is out there
and what fraction
can we possibly
access through bioCADDIE?
Yes.
Well--
Is this is an
impossible question?
No.
I think the good
thing is at least,
the repositories, we
know which ones they are,
what they are doing.
And we also know
those repositories
related to articles.
Because those are increasingly
more prominent and more
available.
What we don't know,
and actually what
we don't know if
we really want, is
from the long tail of
those datasets that
have not been indexed and are
potentially available but not
findable, we don't know
the quality of all of that.
So how do you know that
something is good enough
to appear in a search engine
that has quality control on top
of it?
And you may say, well, maybe
it's not worth doing that
and let the users exert
that quality control.
As of today, and this
may change in the future,
but I believe that
it's important to get
started with some sense
of quality control first.
And, therefore,
many datasets that
has been produced by one
lab or kept there but not
shared, that there might be
some reason why they were not
shared.
So we will not being
addressing those immediately.
I think, as we
progress, and if we
find that the denominator
is not that huge,
then there is a case
for indexing everything.
But probably what we'll find is
it will plateau at some point.
But, again, I can't
tell at this point.
I think it will take another
three or four years for us
to be at that stage that
we can really assess and be
picky about this or that.
OK.
We're starting to get some
questions from the audience.
Probably the most important
comment that we've seen so far
comes from Marjorie
Mitchell who says,
you're doing awesome work.
Thank you.
I read that.
OK.
I have a question asking
whether imaging data can
be indexed with bioCADDIE, can
it be linked with Omics data.
And, ultimately, will bioCADDIE
give you one-stop shopping
so that you can have
a single search that
will provide results from a
variety of these kind of data
sources?
That is my goal.
And when I mentioned
that very first use case,
I want to have all data about
this particular condition
because I want to correlate it.
I want to find
recurrence of a tumor
through images or through data
that shows increases in sizes
and so on.
So that's exactly the point
of getting an uber index that
would then point
to the sources that
have more detailed information.
And if that's Omics, there
are a certain repositories.
If that's imaging, there is
also, through the BD2K centers,
excellent sources of
indexing of images.
So I think that our point
is exactly this integration.
And you find things that
you didn't know about.
Another questioner
mentions that you
alluded to aggregating
patient data and points
to the problem of there
not being unique patient
identifiers that make it easy
to bring patient data together
and questions, how do you
deal with that problem?
How do you deal
with missing data?
How do you deal with
double counting data?
What are the challenges in
doing this kind of aggregation?
These challenges are multiple.
I mean, they not only come
from the privacy end of things,
but exactly what you
mentioned, the duplication
of patients across
different datasets
is a huge problem today
for research studies.
So bioCADDIE will not-- again,
I will be very happy when
we are at that point,
but right now, it's
more at the point of
that, oh, this exists.
And this Count
Everything project
was the first attempt to see
how we would link-- because one
dataset has mutations, another
dataset has sensor data,
another dataset
has clinical data.
Assuming we have
the same patient
represented in all
those three, how
we would do a secure
linkage and also
privacy preserved in
secure linkage of records
so we could do this
de-duplication.
So that's a very
important research area
that I encourage
more people to get
involved because it's
really going to be
a bottleneck in the future.
OK.
A corollary, that is how is
the identification managed
by bioCADDIE?
Again, we do not delve
into the datasets.
Therefore, the de-identification
is not an issue
because we're mostly dealing
at the metadata level.
So if you want all
African-American patients
with TP 53 mutation of a
certain type, initially,
what we can point
is to datasets that
have that type of metadata that
would have race and ethnicity
and would have mutations or it
would have gene information.
But unless we delve
into the dataset,
we can't count the number.
So at this point,
re-identification
through our index
is not an issue.
Lots more questions
coming in, Lucila.
This one is interesting.
Do you have any tips for
searching with DataMed?
People have intuition about
how to optimize their Google
searches, but are there
any good heuristics or ways
in which users can optimize
their efficiency in exploring
data searches which is something
that is not necessarily
intuitive to most people?
Yeah, well, what I'll do is
I will go to Advanced Search
because that might
not be immediately
obvious in the interface.
But there is--
just as in PubMed--
a way not to just go in and
type what your search is,
but to structure it better.
I'm trying to get to the slide
that has the interface here.
Yeah, here.
So see there is on the
right-hand side an Advanced
Search.
So I think that's the
best way to go about it.
And then as you
get your answers,
you can filter by
the repositories,
by the data types, on
this left-hand side.
And you can also
check the synonyms
that it's getting for you.
Because the engine, once you
type something at the top,
it uses that terminology
search to go about synonyms
and expand hierarchically
that concept.
So I think that those would
be ways to get started.
And also, feedback,
let me put it here.
If you have feedback
about something
we should be filtering
by and we're not doing,
that would be very important
for us to know as well.
Please do contribute
your comments.
Along those lines,
a questioner asks,
how are data errors and
inconsistencies found, flagged,
and corrected?
Do you actually have a
mechanism for giving feedback
to the repository managers?
Yes.
So I would use this GitHub.
You click here and
you put your issue
there so that someone
can respond to you.
And if those
corrections are needed,
that's an excellent
way to provide us
with that information.
OK.
Two related questions,
one of which
is, how can someone
get a list of all
the collaborators in bioCADDIE.
And are there librarians
working on the project?
Yes, there are librarians.
The list, if you go
Biocaddie.org-- unfortunately,
we need to work
on the interface.
If you go to working
groups, you will
see everyone listed under
a working group there.
So I would say the list is
scattered into the working
groups.
There isn't a consolidated list.
But if that's desirable,
that's something
that we should probably do.
Because then I can put a link
on my acknowledgments lines
to that particular list.
And that will cover everyone.
Great idea.
Thank you.
Lucila, you stated that you
had certain expectations
about searching data
when you created DataMed.
And the questioner
wants to know,
did anything surprise
you in your findings
as you created the tool?
Yeah, well, it is
still surprising me
because if I were
to say I'm satisfied
and I can do that
query in the beginning,
that was something I
really wanted to do,
was as a friend of
the family, I wanted
to know what is the survival
for a particular age
group, a young person, and I
think I'm not satisfied yet.
You know, we can find some
certain things there right now,
but we don't have enough
imaging repositories,
and I know that
those are coming,
so it's not like
we're not able to,
but it's not populated
to the extent
that I would like at this point.
I mean, it is much
better than if I
go on Google and search for it
because it's essentially very
hard to find
anything that is more
data-centric in the current
Google search engine.
But still, again, my surprise
is that it's not as simple.
I started this project with
a much more naive approach.
This is a lot of
work, but it's simple.
And now, it's a lot of
work and it's not simple.
That's for sure.
Another question-- how are
you encouraging researchers
to deposit their data
into repositories?
Isn't this just a lot
more work for them?
And what is bioCADDIE doing
to get access to more data?
Yeah, so, again, that's
where the data citation
groups are working on it and
also what the incentives are.
I think we do need help with
that because remember when
it happened that journals
started requiring deposit
of data in order to
publish an article,
people started doing it.
Again, not perfect
metadata, but at least data
were deposited and so on.
It so happened that there were
repositories ready for that.
What happens now is
there are certain data
types in certain modalities that
you don't have repositories.
Or, I mean, you may have, but
they're not as recognizable
as those were when
the journalists made
that requirement.
So I think we need to create,
again, this market for data
repositories that are
beyond what exists already
for other data types.
And then with the
publications, which
are still important for
the academic community,
require that.
And then have the funding
agencies provide incentives
for people to comply with that.
A questioner wants
to know how users
might be engaged in
providing feedback
to the DataMed developers.
And how do you ensure that
you're creating a search engine
that people actually
want versus one that you
think they might want?
Yes, exactly.
And that's where,
again, I'll get
to this point of providing
the feedback through GitHub
or through contacting any of
us because each person has
a different idea of
what they would want
from a search engine on data.
So that's also the reason
we had those pilot project
solicitations and so on
because it is different
and everyone is different.
We want to know how can
we cover the 80% most
common expectations
and then also learn
about others so that in the
future we can produce those.
So the best thing is to provide
feedback through this GitHub
link, which is here.
So noted.
We have very little time left.
Let me be very selective in
posing some questions to you,
Lucila.
Here's one that says,
a dataset actually
gets used and re-used-- or
rather, as a dataset actually
gets used and re-used,
and suitability
for different purposes
can become clearer,
is there now in your
scheme, or do you
envision developing,
rules for data users
to supplement data
supplier's metadata
with usage notes, caveats,
bug reports, et cetera.
In other words, I guess, how
do you make DataMed two-way?
Yes.
So that's one thing
that we were thinking,
too, that with more volume
and if we could-- for example,
we are looking at it's screen
right now-- if we could have
for each one of those
entries, the number
of stars, the reviews
from people-- I liked it
or no I didn't like
it, similar to when
you were buying a
product on Amazon-- I
think that would be very good.
We do need to create that
feedback mechanism in here.
And then we need to, obviously,
start getting a lot of usage
to it so that we go
from several reviews.
But I think that's
a goal definitely.
A good question from
a user is, can you
say something more about
how bioCADDIE actually
facilities data re-use?
Yeah, at this point I
wouldn't go that far.
I would say we're trying to
address the findability of it.
So indirectly if
you find it, you're
more likely to re-use it,
but that's not a guarantee.
It might have access
controls that you are not
able to fulfill the
requirements and so on.
So I think it's a step
towards reusability,
but it's run of
several components that
need to be in place so
that it can be re-used.
And this feedback,
again, is very important
because people
have to access it.
People have to use it and
then provide feedback.
Yes, this was useful for me.
Or, no, this dataset
looked good on the outside,
but once I got it, it's
really not that useful.
We're just about at
the end of the hour.
Several questioners would
like to know how they
can get ahold of your slides.
I will provide it
to the organizers.
And also, let me
make a point, I'll
put it on the
Biocaddie.org website.
Thanks, Lucila.
And let me let the audience
know that this talk was recorded
and will eventually be on
the website for the training
coordinating center, which is
providing an archive of all
of the webinars in the series.
At this point, we
are out of time.
Let me thank Lucila
Ohno-Machado for what was
a really exciting presentation.
Let me thank all of you for
some really great questions
and remind you that
we do this every week.
And we look forward to next
week's presentation as well.
Thanks, everyone.
Thank you.